Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy has
been asked to weigh in about the looming
charges against the failed former
president Donald Trump
and when he was given the opportunity to
weigh in
he mentioned Hillary Clinton
I know it seems It seems impossible
they're not it's not they're not doing
it again are they yes Kevin McCarthy
brought up Hillary Clinton I'm almost
ready to declare that Hillary Clinton
must pay for the crimes of Donald Trump
why not right hold her accountable here
is the Speaker of the House
yesterday into the prosecutor
raised a lot of concerns about the
prosecutor but what about the actual
allegations here that the former
president may have falsified this is
Manu Raju from CNN by the way
look the thing I think about
um
it was interesting someone someone
briefed me on
um
the use of money a situation like this
before and you probably covered this
remember when
the DNC and Hillary Clinton paid the law
firm a million dollars but and said that
it was for something else and we found
out later it wasn't it was a wait a
second Kevin that doesn't sound like
you're answering the question about the
Russia collusion it wasn't for legal
part and so they went through
and they got investigated a million
dollars they spent and you know what at
the end of the day they didn't get
prosecuted they got fined Hillary's
campaign got fined eight thousand
dollars and
um the DNC got fined a hundred thousand
dollars even though they used a million
dollars
they knowingly hid the fact of what they
were doing to try to hide
um they got investigated so I look at it
from this perspective please we live in
America it should be equal justice
um this was personal money
it's one tried to hide this was seven
years ago statute limitation and I think
in your heart of hearts you know too
that you think this is just political
and I think that's what the rest of the
country thinks and we're kind of tired
of that understand that Kevin McCarthy
gives a 90-second answer or about a
minute if it took 20 20 or so seconds to
ask the question he gives about a minute
answer
the question is about the looming arrest
and indictment of a president
and all he talks about is Hillary
Clinton you have to hand it to him he's
been trained pretty damn well deflect
deny and distract when it comes to
Donald Trump and his criminal actions
and the is it gaslighting a couple
people wrote to me and said David this
this is essentially gaslighting that's
that's what Kevin McCarthy is doing here
he's gaslighting the media well yeah
it's an attempt at gaslighting but it's
a very transparent one and I don't know
that this is going to work I don't know
that people are necessarily going to be
going for this and it's particularly
ironic that Kevin McCarthy says well we
want equal justice if it's one thing for
a republican then it's another thing for
a Democrat but you know that Kevin
McCarthy doesn't actually want equal
justice or at least his party doesn't
when it comes to actually trying to
create
equal situations where we say well the
rich and the poor are treated
differently by the justice system we
should equalize that now they don't they
don't actually care about that well
we're seeing dramatically different
outcomes
uh in all sorts of different measures of
attainment based on whether people live
by no fault of their own uh in poor
versus wealthy neighborhoods let's do
something about that now that sounds
like woke nonsense they want equality
when it's convenient for them and then
otherwise they go equality that's just
that woke nonsense that you guys won't
stop talking about so Kevin McCarthy it
took him a few days to be ready with the
talking points but it's all Hillary
Clinton all the time and we'll break
down I mean I I do think
I'm of two minds on the one hand if I
spend a lot of time myself talking about
how the Hillary Clinton situation he
references was very different I'm sort
they're kind of winning right because I
start talking about Hillary
at the same time it might be worth doing
a run-through of the Hillary Clinton
situation he's talking about and why it
is so dramatically different from what
Trump is embroiled in right now let me
know in the comments
should I do that segment about how the
Hillary situation is different or should
I ignore it all together because exactly
what they want is for people talking
about Hillary Clinton instead of Donald
Trump let me know in the comments and
I'm at your mercy whatever it is you
want me to do I will do